Speaker 1: The Pennsylvania Senate race is one of
the most interesting elections this midterm cycle,
as it presents Democrats with an opportunity to
pick up a seat in the upper chamber and add to
their majority. Democratic nominee John Fetterman
is up against Republican Mehmet Oz, and this race
was considered a toss up just a couple of months
ago. But it's now looking like Fetterman really
is pulling away. The FiveThirtyEight average
of polling has Fetterman up by 11 points 49%
to 38%. And part of this can be expected because
Pennsylvania, still, after all, is a blue state.
Yes, they did vote for Trump in 2016. They've put
people in power like Rick Santorum and Pat Toomey.
But this is still blue territory, we can say. But
another part of the reason is that Mehmet Oz, Dr.
Oz, he really just seems to be a lot weaker of a
candidate than many of us even expected. He's been
painted successfully as a carpetbagger because
he's from New Jersey. He's been painted as an
elitist, which is also true because he has a net
worth of about $100 million with ten houses. More
on that later. On today's bonus show, we actually
talked earlier in the week on the bonus show about
his crew to take video, which was filmed back
in April. But it's going viral now. And John
Fetterman was mocking him for it because he didn't
know the name of the grocery store that he was in.
He didn't know how buying vegetables works. And
oftentimes the price that's listed is the price
per pound versus the price per vegetable. So
the Fetterman campaign was having a field day
trolling him for that. Well, the OSI team is
realizing that they have to make up some ground
and they've decided to go on the offense. They did
so by releasing an attack ad on John Fetterman,
and I don't think it's going to work out too
well for them. Let's take a look at the ad.
Speaker 3: Now that John Fetterman claims to be
recovering. Let's pull back his hoodie and examine
what's in his head. Looks like he has some screws.
What's this? That one wants to release one third
of all prisoners. That's crazy. To spend more tax
dollars, everything will cost more. That's nuts.
Slow energy production. Gas prices will
skyrocket. That's ridiculous. Socialized
medicine. Get these crazy ideas, and now it
makes a mess. Well, Bob, let her close it up.
John Fetterman is crazier than you think.
Speaker 1: All right, so in the ad,
they attack John Fetterman for wearing a hoodie,
which actually can be argued is an asset for him.
The fact that he just dresses like the average
Pennsylvania dude, he's not trying to be anything
that he's not. He's not wearing a suit and
tie just for the show. He likes wearing his
basketball shorts and his sweatshirts. So
I don't know if that's going to be all that
effective for the odd campaign. Then there's
this bong that pops out of veteran's head,
and I couldn't find out whether Fetterman himself
uses cannabis, but he is one of the most pro weed
politicians in America. He supported it long
before it was politically popular to do so.
And the latest poll that I could find was that 58%
of Pennsylvanians support legalizing marijuana. So
I don't see how that is much of an attack either.
Then there's this bit about releasing a third of
prisoners while we do have the world's highest
prison population. And if you're talking about
releasing people who are nonviolent, people who
are maybe drug offenders, that sort of thing,
yeah, they should be let out of prison. That's
totally cool. By the way, I thought Republicans
were all of a sudden more amenable to this idea of
prison and criminal justice reform, because they
think that the January 6th rioters are spending
too much time behind bars. Maybe they forgot about
that over at the Oz campaign. Then there's the
thing about slowing energy production. Clearly,
that's over the course of many years and decades,
though, to move in the direction of renewable
power that will ultimately save people money, by
the way, and save the planet in the long term.
And then they put up the phrase free health care
being held up on a sign by AOC, which they should
have known that they shouldn't have used the
term free health care, universal health care.
It would have been much better if they used
the term government takeover of health care,
they said in the ad, socialized medicine, but they
should have put that on the sign as well, because
that's the type of phrase that polls a lot better
for Republicans. And then out pops Bernie Sanders,
who is apparently the one who's really controlling
John Fetterman. If you vote for John Fetterman,
you're actually getting Bernie Sanders. I think
this is another blunder, too, because, yeah,
Bernie wasn't popular enough to win the Democratic
primary, for example, either in 2016 or 2020. But
he is quite popular as a politician. People think
that he's principled and he's especially popular
in the Northeast, in states like Vermont, where he
represents. And, you know, Pennsylvania is pretty
close by, too, so I'd imagine he's pretty popular
there. So even though I'm no Republican, I think
that I could have done a much better job at making
this attack ad on John Fetterman, because this
just looks absolutely cartoonish. It's a terrible
presentation, very over-the-top. And I think the
team could have done a lot better. Let's hope that
Fetterman is able to grow or at least maintain his
lead will be able to land Donald Trump another
loss if Fetterman picks up the victory here. But
you know what Trump will do? If Mehmet Oz ends
up losing, he'll just distance himself from
Oz and say, Well, Austin, it really run all
that close to me. And that's why he lost. But
nonetheless, it will be a glorious victory if
we're able to pick up this seat in Pennsylvania.